conservative internet meme artist
Douglas Mackey has officially been
sentenced by an Obama judge to 7 months
in prison for posting moderately funny
memes the memes are just a riff on an
old political joke in which you instruct
your co-partisans to vote the right way
and your opponents to vote the wrong way
the joke usually goes hey Republicans
vote on Tuesday oh you're a Democrat
I'll vote on Wednesday don't forget you
got to vote not one minute sooner than
Wednesday that kind of thing here's one
of the jokes that he posted this is
Hillary it looks like a Hillary ad but
it's obviously not one because it says
vote for her vote from home post Hillary
using # presidential election saying on
November 8th type the word Hillary and
post it to Twitter or Facebook using the
hashtag presidential election between
7:00 a.m. and 9:00 p.m. Eastern to cast
your vote from Hillary from home
stronger together and then it says
powered by Microsoft so if you if you
were too dull to know that this was a
joke from the beginning if you were too
uninformed about how our government
works to know that you can't vote by
posting to Twitter uh if you if you just
missed the joke at the bottom there the
powered by Microsoft I think forces you
to get that it's a joke because
presumably Microsoft is not supposed to
be running our elections I guess
actually sorry I should take that back
because we're living in a day and age in
which Google and Facebook have much more
control over our elections than ordinary
people and Mayors and townships and
States so you're right maybe you miss
that but truly if you mistake this for
real campaign
instructions you should not vote
certainly not you should you probably
shouldn't be able to live on your own so
impaired must you be uh in your basic
functioning here's another
meme again posted by Douglas Mackey save
time avoid the line vote from home text
Hillary to
59925 and we'll make history together
this November 8th and uh the key here
too is not only are these obviously
jokes they're memes but they're being
posted from an account with a magah hat
on from from Douglas Mackey's account
they're being posted by people who then
when they repost it they say at the
Ricky vaugh that was his handle thanks
for spreading the word # Maga # I'm with
her #v Hillary from home save time and
avoid the line so they're even using the
hashtag Maga they're using the the Trump
hashtag CU it's obviously a joke and for
those mildly spicy memes Mackey is going
to prison because in the words of Judge
obam Haack the memes constituted quote a
scheme to deprive individuals of their
constitutional right to vote and were
therefore quote nothing short of an
assault on our
democracy
so another peaceful conservative
dissident goes to the clink to join the
midwestern Granny's and the pro- lifers
and all the other people who have had
the tarity to express their political
views and oppose the ruling class what
sort of government do they think this is
I'm Michael nolles this is the Michael
nlls
Show
[Music]
in just a moment we will see a nun
tackle a leftist climate protester which
is a great joy we'll get to that in a
moment first though I don't want to move
off our democracy too quickly is are we
living is that with this is this a
democracy I if this is democracy I I
think our Founding Fathers deserve a
refund if expressing even the mildest
funniest most anod ways your opposition
to the liberal ruling class is a threat
to our democracy and it means you got to
go to prison for months and months at a
time if not years I think democracy
doesn't quite mean what they think it
means here is Nancy Pelosi suggesting
that if Republicans elect a speaker of
the house that she doesn't like if they
vote if the representatives in the
government vote and then most of them
get what they
want that's a threat to democracy it is
a reminder that the speaker is second in
line to the presidency and when you had
a president who was refusing to be
president and you had a vice president
who was hiding and fearing for his life
it was the speaker who had to take
charge and you did that the idea that
the person in that position if something
catastrophic were to happen to the
capital again would be an
insurrectionist somebody who was on the
side of the insurrectionist I can't wrap
my mind around it fully and I wonder
what you make of it the public has to
understand what is at stake our
democracy is at stake what have the
Republicans accomplished it all even
when they had a president in the White
House from time to time an enormous tax
cut for the super rich in corporations
now some of them said this is a bridge
too far right for our democracy and we
respect differences of opinion that's
our democracy we welcome the fry the
conversation the debate that it's not a
question of I don't like what you
believe so therefore uh you're not right
no that's your right you represent your
district and that's it but if you're not
honoring the oath of office if you don't
respect our democracy
that is a that is a a line that cannot
be crossed how many times did she say
democracy it's like a stutter with her
every manam what would you like for
lunch I think I would democracy have the
Double Quarter democracy Pounder with
democracy cheese and maybe uh manam
would you like a medium or a large I'd
like a democracy uh large I want a large
democ ice diet democracy diet democracy
democracy Coke democracy or sacred
democracy and I love she says look it's
not about differences of opinion you
have a difference of opinion I respect
that if you disagree with me look we the
people we we debate it we discuss we
come to conclusions but if I actually
disagree with you then it's a threat to
democracy you see if you see if you
disagree with me in a kind of pretend
way like a Mitt Romney kind of way where
you you push back a little tiny bit but
then ultimately it's your job just to
lose and to roll over and let us us win
then obviously that's wonderful for our
sacred democracy but if you actually
defend the interests of your
constituents and you actually make
reasoned arguments that defeat my
reasoned arguments well then you're an
insurrectionist and you go to prison
because you're a threat to that uh
obviously by
definition whatever the the most people
vote
for is a an expression of the
Democracy
always it's not the way that the
Liberals currently say it is which is if
most people vote for Obama democracy is
working if most people vote for Trump
democracy is under threat if most people
vote for Orban in Hungary democracy is
on the verge of Extinction if most
people vote for the brexit in the UK or
they vote for Maloney in Italy or any
other right-wing government that's
that's a grave threat that's that's of
course not it in that case they're
confusing liberalism and democracy which
are different things liberal liberalism
is is an ideology it could be held by a
minority of people it usually is held by
a minority of people but they conflate
the two things so they say oh the vast
majority of people voted for Donald
Trump well that's a threat to democracy
because does democracy means liberalism
so she's making a very stupid point
there but she she does get to a kernel
of Truth and I haven't heard anyone else
point out the little tiny grain of truth
that ironically Democrats like Nancy
Pelosi are showing they're revealing
when they make this point which we'll
get to in one second first though want
to talk about your dog and what your dog
is eating and I want to talk about Ruff
greens right now go to Ruff greens.com
you know I'm not a dog person I'm a
people person but my stepbrother he has
a little dog and while I'm lukewarm on
my step brother you know the dog should
be healthy which is why I sent him rough
greens and they absolutely love it
naturopathic doctor Dennis black the
founder of rough greens is focused on
improving the health of every dog in
America dog food may as well be
considered dead food because it contains
very little nutritional content think
about it nutrition is not brown it's
green let rough greens bring your dogs
food back to life rough greens how many
times am I going to say it a lot is a
supplement that contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food just sprinkle rough Greens on your
food every single day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough greens
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath boosts energy levels it does a
whole lot more than that and right now
my listeners are going to get a free
jump start trial bag so that your dog
can try it get that free jump start
trial bag delivered straight to your
door just a few business days Ru
greens.com or call 844
rf123 rfffg greens.com
or call 844
rf123 today the nearest thing to a
coherent point that Nancy Pelosi is
making when she says that
most people voting for conservatives
threatens
democracy is
that democracy can undo
itself so for instance if most people
went to The Ballot Box and they voted
for a ballot proposition that said that
we're going to cease to be a democracy
and become a monarchy and we're going to
elect King Donaldo Maximus and he will
reign as the great Caesar for a thousand
years uh and they voted for that that
would be the Democracy undoing itself
now of course that's not what anyone has
done here in fact Donald Trump ran on a
much more pro-democratic platform than
his liberal opponent certainly than
Hillary Clinton Jim Jordan is running on
a much more pro-democracy platform for
speaker of the house than many speakers
than basically any speaker we've had in
recent history but in principle a
democracy could undo itself and in fact
Nancy Pelosi is right that our sacred
democracy faces a threat of undoing
itself
from her
side that's the part she's missing
that's the part all the Democrats are
missing it's not the right-wing
Republicans who are threatening
democracy it's the Democrats who are
undermining the very uh pre-requisites
of democracy the most often cited quote
on this front is from John Adams who
says that our constitution is built for
a moral and religious
people and in 2023 we read that qu we
say oh isn't that sweet John Adams liked
religion he actually didn't like
religion all that much he wasn't even
remotely an Orthodox
Christian but he recognized that if you
lost religion you would lose morality
and if you lost morality the
Constitution would be worthless it would
just be a dead sheet of paper with no
enforcement
mechanism that has undermined our sacred
democracy sometimes people will also
pedantically point out that we are a
republic not a democracy which is Hal
true it's Hal true in the sense that
we're obviously not a direct democracy
like certain Societies in Antiquity but
we're we're a representative Republic
okay sure but actually the way that the
framers of our Constitution use the the
words democracy and Republic in The
Federalist Papers very confused and they
sometimes point to ancient republics as
democracies and vice versa so anyway it
broadly speaking we are mostly a
democracy frankly the way the
Constitution was set up is a little
closer to what Thomas aquinus described
as the ideal poity which is that you've
got a monarchical element in the United
States in the person of the president
then you've got an aristocratic
representation you see this in
institutions like the Senate you see
this in the representation for the
States you see this in the way that
landed gentry had more political Sway
and then you see a strong Democratic
representation too we have that we've
undermined a lot of it the the biggest
thing undermining it is the loss of
religion and morality that is being
driven not entirely but almost
exclusively by the Democrats you want to
whine and cry about the loss of our
sacred democracy blame Nancy Pelosi so
where does our sacred Democracy stand
where does Jim Jordan's race
stand it's not looking great you know I
I love Jim Jordan the only reason that I
I didn't immediately endorse him for
speaker is because I like him too much
and I think he's a good guy and I think
being the Republican speaker of the
house is the worst job in Washington DC
I'm sure he'd be great at it but I I
wouldn't wish that I'm worst enemy
anyway Jim threw his hat in the ring and
he he ended up beating out Steve scales
Who first got the nomination then didn't
have the votes he dropped out of the
race now Jim Jordan's up he went up for
the vote and lost and then they went up
for a second vote he lost again a total
of 199 members voted for Jim Jordan
yesterday which means he Lo he lost by a
greater margin than he had the day
before he lost he ended up losing one
additional vote cuz he previously had
gotten 200 votes the day before so now
they're 22 Republican defectors voting
for other people in the
GOP uh hakee Jeff ended up getting more
votes 212 but not enough to elect him
speaker so now what are we going to do
well this was always the fear in fact I
think this is why Jim Jordan did not
vote to oust Kevin McCarthy is because
there wasn't much of a plan on who was
going to replace him Steve scales he
didn't have the votes Jim Jordan doesn't
currently have the votes I hope he gets
them who what are they going to do one
possibility is to expand the powers of
the temporary house Speaker Patrick
McKenry so Patrick McKenry just by
default gets this position as the
temporary speaker of the house but he
doesn't really have virtually any of the
power of the speaker of the house so one
solution that's been proposed is to just
give him those Powers passed as a as an
act of Congress and then uh once he has
those Powers they can kind of get
through this term and then figure out
what happens in 2024
uh not ideal not a great way for the
Republicans to exercise power it seems
to me we've got a very slim majority and
uh We've Democrats have the Senate
Democrats have the White House Democrats
have the Deep State and the media and
the universities and virtually every
Power Center in the country so who the
holdouts on Jim Jordan 22 of them
they're virtually all
squishes maybe not every single pretty
much every single one of them though
they're squishes they're liberals
Sabers they're they're just awful and
they need to get on board because if
they don't then the Republicans will be
seeding the very little control that
they currently have in the government
and maybe that's what these squishes
wanted the whole time maybe that's what
these limp Republicans impotent
Republicans always kind of wanted the
reason that being the Republican speaker
of the house is the worst job in the
country in certainly in Washington DC is
is because the Democrats are all on the
same page with the exception of Joe
mansion and maybe Kirsten Cinema they're
all Progressive leftists there there is
barely a blue dog left in the bunch so
they're all on the same page and they
can they can join together and act and
and throw their weight around because
they're unified the Republicans are not
the Republicans have conservatives the
Republicans have Libertarians the
Republicans have liberals the
conservatives have the the self-styled
moderates the conservatives have the
Chamber of Commerce people they're
they're desperate factions and they
don't have a ton bringing them together
so they're going to hang apart and what
these squishes are saying is they're
saying look I would rather give
Democrats much more control over the
House of Representatives and have nearly
unified control over the government than
Empower one of those mean old
conservatives Jim Jordan too by the way
because Jim Jordan has very conservative
beliefs but he is as respectable a guy
in Congress as their possibly could be
he is as decent a guy as you're going to
find in the House of Representatives and
if he is too too far and crazy and
right-wing for them then they're just
not conservative which means that the
the five person Republican majority was
largely
ucer because we weren't able to get a
speaker yes they kind of agreed on Kevin
McCarthy but the only way that Kevin
finally got his speakership the first
time the only time I guess is when he
conceded so much of his power that they
were able to depose him N9 months later
basically the same thing happened with
Paul Ryan Paul Ryan was a compromised
cidate he didn't ask for the job he
wanted to remain chairman of the budget
committee he was drafted as the only
person who could bring the the factions
of the GOP together and then he left in
ignominy nobody liked him by the time he
left how about uh John Boehner John
Boehner deeply unpopular speaker no one
likes him now he basically just shills
for Democrats while he's sipping red
wine and smoking a Sig on the cover of
his tellall book bashing
conservatives we just don't we just
don't have any ability to to function as
Republicans at the national level in
Washington DC one of the reasons I was a
little skeptical of Ting mcarthy
although that it was that that fate was
sealed the moment that McCarthy made his
deal with the conservatives to become
speaker in the first place so where do
we go from here we either go to speaker
Jordan or we lose a lot of power that's
where we go ultimately though ultimately
regardless of who becomes speaker the
Deep
state which is the spooky term for the
federal bureaucracy perfectly ordinary
political concept that we all know about
nothing conspiratorial about it at all
the Deep State's going to do what it
wants to do regardless of what Congress
does in fact here's how we know this
Wall Street Journal just reports and the
Pentagon doesn't deny that 2,000 US
troops have been told to prepare to
deploy to help the state of Israel
against Hamas and whichever other Middle
Eastern Nations get involved in the
war Pentagon said yes okay roughly uh
2,000 US troops were
told uh quote I don't have more to
provide at this time I might be able to
give you more details later but at this
time I just don't have anything more
specific to add that's according to the
deputy press secretary Sabrina Singh of
the
Pentagon and this to me is the best and
worst part of the House of
Representatives failure to govern this
is the best and the worst part of The
house's failure to pass a budget in
recent years this is the best and worst
part of The house's failure to even have
a speaker is it shows you just how
little Congress has to do with our
actual
government it's this is the the best
part of it in that it it rips off the
facade remember remember back in what
was it July maybe it was a little
earlier when there was a big hubbub
about fund the war in Ukraine and people
didn't want to fund the war in Ukraine
most Americans don't want to fund that
war certainly most Republicans don't
want to fund that war so Congress was
saying no no more funding for Ukraine
and what happened the Deep State came
out and they said oh hey we found $6
billion that's not even exactly how they
said it because that claim gets 10
pinocchios on the fact check but it's
effectively what they said because they
said well actually look in that money
that was already allocated we sent some
weapons over to Ukraine and we've
decided after the fact that the weapons
were worth less than we said they were
worth so uh yeah how did we decide that
I don't know we just I don't know we got
new analysts and they said that actually
the guns and the tanks and the whatever
they're worth a lot less so that means
we'd already allocated the money it
means effectively we've got another $6
billion Congress didn't allocate it we
just sort of found it in the couch
cushions and we're going to send more
weapons over to Ukraine okay easy we
don't need to talk to a single stupid
Congressman to get that kind of money
it's the same
all of these government shutdowns in
recent years they don't impede the the
function of of government really at all
why because our duly elected
representatives of our sacred democracy
that the Democrats never shut up about
don't really seem to have all that much
to do with our actual government when
you want to learn about our government a
lot of other things you got to go check
out Hillsdale right now go to
hillsdale.edu NES are you a few years or
decades out of school and wondering what
the heck did I even learn and what was
the point you might even be thinking I
don't have the time to learn something
new well if that's you you're not alone
and it's not too late Hillsdale College
is offering more than 40 free online
courses learn about the works of CS
Lewis the rise and fall of the Roman
Republic or the history of the ancient
Christian church with Hillsdale
College's online courses if you are not
sure where to start check out CS Lewis
on Christianity in this seven lecture
course you will examine some of Lewis's
classic Works including Mere
Christianity the screw tape letters and
the abolition of man you'll also see
what Lewis had to say about scripture
prayer suffering Joy Heaven and Hell the
course is self-paced so that you can
start whenever and wherever enroll now
in CS Lewis on Christianity to discover
Lewis's core lessons on Christianity and
how to apply Faith to your life go to
hillsdale.edu to enroll no cost easy to
get started hillsdale.edu NS
hillsdale.edu
if you've not heard the news bent key
our new kids content app that launched
on Monday is now officially the number
one Kids Entertainment app you should
know this because it was you who made it
number one by downloading the new beny
app and experiencing it for yourself you
once again have a space with shows made
for kids that they will love and you can
trust the kind of content that we had
growing up and just like when we were
growing up new episodes are released
every Saturday morning you know I woke
up my eldest son today sweet little boy
2 and a half years old and he was
hugging his little chip chill
stuffed animal we that's one of the
perks of employment here we got the
stuffed animals before anyone else did
and he was holding he loved it he took
wanted to bring it downstairs absolutely
loves it so right now consider this your
invitation to join the number one kids
app by downloading it today if you're
already a DW annual member I've got
exciting news for you you've already got
full access to all of Ben Key's
incredible shows at no extra cost this
would typically cost 99 bucks it is
included in your annual daily wire
membership for free you can get beny now
at Daily wire.com
subscribe speaking of that war in Israel
and now throughout the Middle
East there's a story that happened a
couple days ago about a hospital struck
by some kind of explosive and I didn't
cover it on the show and my producers
said aren't you going to cover the
hospital story and I said what am I
going to cover said well you know the
story about how the thing exploded and
how it was conversely
the Palestinian Islamic Jihad that
misfired a rocket and the rocket
accidentally hit the hospital and it
killed 500 people or some say it was a
missile from Israel and it hit the
hospital and now Israel was lying about
it to cover up their tracks or it was a
missile that hit from either the Islamic
Jihad or from Israel and it only hit a
parking lot and it hit a parking lot but
people still died but was it 500 people
or there many fewer people died and the
building was slightly damaged but maybe
someone was in the par working lot and
my answer
is I just don't
know I just don't know here's what I
know the state of Israel as a general
rule tries to minimize civilian
deaths Hamas does not try to minimize
civilian deaths we know that for a
fact beyond that we just don't know very
much so if you asked me Michael what's
your hunch was the rocket from Hamas or
was the rocket from the state of Israel
I guess I would say my hunches or rather
from the the Palestinian Islamic Jihad I
guess I would say my
hunches it came from the
jihadis but I don't really know and you
don't really know either and nobody
knows because we're currently in the
heat of war or we're seeing the heat of
War we're seeing the fog of War we're
seeing all of that confusion and we're
being inundated with propaganda from
both sides and so I just don't know the
only thing I not for certain about right
now minute by minute what's going on on
the
ground is that the US interest is to
contain the war that's all I
know that's not the interest of the of
the belligerent in the
war the interest of Hamas and
Palestinian Islamic Jihad and Hezbollah
and Iran is to expand the war to destroy
the state of
Israel the interest of the state of
Israel is to expand the war to destroy
its
enemies Hamas first maybe Hezbollah
maybe Palestinian Islamic Jad maybe
regime change in
Iran those two national interests or I
guess palestine's not a nation state but
those two belligerent interests are not
the same as America's interest America's
interest is to contain the war so this
doesn't become a broader regional
conflict and then a global war that's
going to pull us into it that's our
interest our interests don't always line
we are allies with the state of Israel
so we defend our allies it's an
important part of international
relations and
diplomacy but our foreign interests are
not identical with those of the state of
Israel a key example of this would have
been the negoro carabat conflict that
just took place between the state of
aeran and the Armenians the Muslim
azanis and the Armenian Christians AR
Armenia the oldest Christian nation in
the world in that case the state of
Israel backed aeran I get why the state
of Israel did it it was in the state of
Israel's National interest to counter
other Regional Powers but that would
just be one small example of a place
where our foreign interests diverge and
so we have an alliance with the state of
Israel we're sending aircraft carriers
to the state of Israel we're we're doing
our very level best to contain this
conflict but I do not see an argument as
to how it is in America's interest to
escalate to start bombing the malas in
Iran to do any of these things we have
to be very I know there are plenty of
voices in Washington DC calling for a
broader conflict even as we're seeing
the war in Ukraine bring us already to
the brink of World War II because it's
the first major war in Europe since
World War I already as we're seeing
China begin to aggress in the South
China Sea and on Taiwan bringing us
close as we've been in a long time to
World War I there were some people in
Washington saying let's let the bombs
drop baby let's go uh-uh no
we got to be very very clear about the
US
interest generally speaking do I think
that this Hospital attack was
perpetrated by our Ally the state of
Israel
versus the Islamic
terrorists no I think it prob it
probably was the Islamic
terrorists that's not even my first
question when I look at these kinds of
events my first question is what is the
American interest what is in service of
the cause of Justice what prevents World
War I okay whatever those answers are in
as much as they can align do it we do
not want a global conflict now speaking
of death and crimes a big story on the
cultural front from Britney Spears who
has a book coming out and in the book
she says she had an abortion when she
was younger and while she was dating
Justin
Timberlake which you might recall was
all the media was talk the media was
were talking about Justin and Britney
for like half of my childhood I feel
like and uh apparently there was always
a big question did they or did they not
you know did they do that thing that
only married people are supposed to do
guess the answer was they did and
Britney then became pregnant and then
she says she had an abortion and she
said if it had been left up to me alone
I never would have done it and yet
Justin was so sure that he didn't want
to be a father he said we weren't ready
to have a baby in our lives that we were
way too young to this day it's one of
the most agonizing things I ever
experienced in my life to which I
say many such cases many such cases
there was a young woman who wrote Into
the show this was maybe years ago now
and she said hey Michael I'm I've got an
abortion appointment but I know you're
pro-life so what do you think should I
not do it and my my first response
was do not do not under any circumstance
go through with the
abortion you will regret it the rest of
your
life the reason not to have the abortion
is because you're killing your child the
reason not to have the abortion is
because it's intrinsically unjust but if
you're trying to reach someone just on a
very emotional level even on a very
selfish level make it clear you will
regret it for the rest of your life I
know a number of women who have had
abortions I know some women who have had
multiple
abortions it's very difficult for them
to get over it I'm not they never
totally get over it some of them have
healed and repented and moved on and
lived edifying sanctifying lives but
that's not something you really just
like Get
over and then Britney famously sure not
that long thereafter went completely
crazy and then was placed in a
conservator ship and still exhibits all
these kind of crazy
behaviors you think there might be a
connection
there I've seen that kind of connection
I think I suspect there strongly is it's
like lady MC Beth trying to wipe out the
the blood out damn
spot that's a that's a driver of that I
wonder as we see the explosion of
anxiety and depression and suicidality
and just psychosis among young women the
the the number of young women who have
to be prescribed all these powerful
psych meds right now I wonder if some of
that maybe much of that has to do with a
culture that encourages them to commit
actions that lead to such regret
most clearly abortion but the whole
thing the culture of promiscuity the
hookup culture feminism all the rest of
it might there be a connection between
the insanity that people are expressing
men too men too in a different way the
insanity that people seem to be
displaying today and the insane and
unreasonable behaviors that they engage
in that lead to such regret speaking of
Hollywood people
Millie Bobby Brown who is the star of
stranger things she's the alien girl or
whatever like the it's not an alien
thing it's like whatever the kind of
spooky telepathic girl in stranger
things uh Millie Bobby Brown has said
that she is a
feminist and she knows she is a feminist
because a psychic told her which to me
totally checks out because
psychics gain their dubious insights by
communing with demons so I'm not
surprised at all that a demon would
encourage anyone to be become a feminist
uh in fact I think that's a large driver
of feminism probably you know at least
at least indirectly a lot of people are
laughing at they say you get your
insights from a
psychic yeah of course people do because
people have an a natural inclination
toward the religious and when they don't
practice true religion religion which is
uh a habit of virtue that inclines the
will to give God what he deserves when
you don't uh follow theology which is
Faith seeking understanding applying
logic and reason to our intuitions of
God and our longing for God then you
become the most superstitious person in
the world and you do the crystals and
the horoscopes and the astrology and the
psychics and the The Vibes man and like
the yoga and the feeling the chakras
with the whatever and you just go into
all this kind of
craziness I I don't want to knock Millie
Bobby Brown because she seems actually
pretty promising I why good actress good
little actress and she's very young and
I believe I don't follow these things
closely but I believe she's engaged to
be married and in this this interview
with her and when she talks about the
psychics in Glamour magazine she says
that what she really wants is to have
kids so I don't know I look at a young
actress in Hollywood and she's been a
child star which is something that
really messes virtually everyone up and
she's nevertheless said I want to get
married at a nice young age not too
young but 19 20 it's pretty good get
married young and start having kids and
I think okay I want to encourage her
that's great that's awesome she's still
surrounded by a bunch of wackos in
Hollywood who might be influencing her
with bad things like feminism and
psychics and whatever but she she
clearly has a a
decent core intuition here so she should
follow that and stop listening to Demons
whether those demons sit in Hollywood
producer offices or whether those demons
are uh communicating via psychic media
on the topic of women doing the right
thing this is my favorite video that I
have
seen at least this week maybe this year
and it's of a nun in France a Catholic
nun who is on the site of a new Chapel
that is being built when a bunch of
climate protesters show up these
left-wing Gaia worshipping pagans show
up to destroy the construction site so
what is the nun going to
do is the nun going to just sit meekly
back is the
nun only going to pray I'm sure the nun
was praying about this a lot and that's
very important thing to do that's the
most important thing to do at first but
then there are other things that we can
do such as tackle the climate
protesters There She Goes drag him slay
sister yes get that jerk in the muck
then the other ones go in the keep
trying to destroy the construction
equipment but that sister oh I love it
there are too many pacifists in the
church militant if you ask me I
absolutely love
that you know they say faith without
works is dead which is sometimes
misinterpreted to mean that we can earn
our own salvation through works and
that's not the case God's grace comes
all the way down the mountain we can
cooperate with that Grace or not and and
a a life of faith is going to look like
something and it's going to impel
certain actions such as tackling the
climate activists who are trying to
destroy your property and a beautiful
Chapel that could be built the reason
though that this video really struck me
and I think the reason it's going viral
right now and it pertains to what we
were just talking about with feminism is
under feminism women seem empowered but
are in fact
powerless right women uh they they seem
like they're boss babes but actually
they just get
used by a bunch of men as sexual toys
and then discarded they they are dragged
out for activism you know and they they
smile on camera but then they're
discarded they they're told that they're
empowered to go sit in the office at the
widget Factory and engage in drudgery
all day and have to put off getting
married and have to put off having kids
and have to put off being The Hand That
Rocks the Cradle is the hand that rules
the
world so the pr coming out of media in
Hollywood is these feminist women
they're so empowered but they're
miserable and in fact if you trust
surveys on happiness their happiness
since feminism going back to the very
moment of the rise of feminism their
happiness has declined both absolutely
and relative to men and ironically under
traditional gender
roles women seem subservient women seem
like they're in a secondary role in fact
however they are extremely empowered if
you have ever met a real nun I get to
spend some time with some some sisters
some pro-life sisters in Southern
California at a a pro-life Gala a few
weeks ago these are some of the toughest
ladies you ever saw in your life and
they are doing lots of good and they're
not going to take no for an answer not
certainly not from unjust Authority and
they're they're forces to be reckoned
with you ever meet a true matriarch of a
family often she will defer to her
husband the husband's the head of the
household she will look like a 1950s
housewife she might look like a 1250s
housewife she has a lot of power this is
the meaning of the phrase The Hand That
Rocks the Cradle is the hand that rules
the world the the reason that that is
always the case is because when you live
in accordance with nature and reality
you will succeed more you will be more
perfectly yourself if you try to do the
opposite if if you fall into the the LIE
of feminism which says that the only way
to have power or do good is to act like
a man to put on a suit and in some cases
now to transform your body to look more
like a man uh you're going to be acting
out of accord with nature out of accord
with reality and you're never going to
beat reality you if when when you and
reality go up in the boxing match
reality is always going to win you will
you will become a caricature of yourself
and what you're supposed to be rather
than the perfect version of yourself and
ultimately we reach our full perfection
when we cooperate with God's grace and
accept God's grace which is why that nun
is just absolutely crushing it and
crushing that protester my favorite
comment yesterday is from Chantel XU
4096 who says as a Canadian cream puff
oh how' you do how about that E I was
waiting for Michael to talk about
Pierre Pierre he's the man Pierre
PV who just destroyed that liberal
journalist with facts and apples great
beautiful clip when are we going to get
our Pierre I guess TR Trump is just the
much less polished Pierre you know
Canadians are very nice and so they do
things in a very nice way Americans are
a little more Brash sometimes and we so
it's fitting fitting that we've got our
respective conservative
leaders speaking of empowered women I
have the least surprising story that
you've ever read in the
news you might recall a couple years ago
Victoria's Secret rebranded VI secret
previously advertised their lingerie on
very sexy women and then they said we're
not going to do that anymore we're going
to uh advertise our lingerie on very
obese people and on and
men and kind of
Butch we're not going to no more sexy
women we're just going to do every other
kind of person including dudes and here
you go here's the big surprise they're
selling less
lingerie isn't that weird this all began
because of Megan rapino Megan rapino was
a soccer lady who hated America and she
would pop up in the news when she said
something disparaging about America or
reality or tradition or decency and but
she also happened to play soccer I guess
and so she she blasted Victoria's Secret
and said they were pushing a message
that's really harmful one that was
patriarchal and sexist viewing not just
what it meant to be sexy but what the
clothes were trying to accomplish
through a male lens and through what men
desired and you see Megan rapino was a
lesbian and it's 2023 and everybody's
supposed to be a lesbian and nobody's
supposed to be normal ever and we're
supposed to take the views that were
previously on the kind of fringes of
society and that were a bit eccentric
and those are supposed to be normal and
anyone who has normal desires or
behaviors they should be outcast they
should be thrown into the outer Darkness
where there's wailing and nashing of
teeth and they should not get their
Victoria Secret catalog with the pretty
ladies in it uh-uh that's very wrong and
sexist and patriarchal and whatever so
then they rebranded the the company they
don't they don't don't even do the
annual fashion show the annual fashion
show is gone that's been gone for five
years now and they got really good
reviews from the critics this is just
like rotten tomatoes when some liberal
movie comes out and the critics say oh
95% it's amazing it's so beautiful and
it's about you know lesbian Cowboys on a
mountain somewhere and they say oh this
the greatest movie ever and then the
audience score is like 5% because no one
actually wants to see it because while
it it might press some ideological
buttons that the critics like it's not
actually entertaining and it's not a
good
movie Victoria Secrets projected revenue
for this year is $6.2 billion which is a
lot of money but it's 5% lower than last
year and it's even lower than the $7.5
billion that it had in Revenue in
2020 that's a big that's a big
difference 7.5 billion down to 6.2
billion in three years that's a collapse
of your
company why
because no amount of activism will ever
change human nature no amount of
activism will ever change the
fundamentals of
reality this is what CS Lewis means when
he when he mocks the atheist and he says
he's not worried about atheists because
atheists can no more change God's
existence then a lunatic in his padded
cell can can blot out the Sun by writing
Darkness on the walls of those cell you
just simply don't have the power to do
that and yet they go on and the rinos of
the world and the feminists and the LGBT
act and all the activ s they that's why
they scream that's why they yell and
they scream in the street because their
preference is out of accord with reality
and reality is always going to win and
they're always going to be
frustrated the more you try to deny
reality which is what we've all been
told to do for the last 30 years at
least really the last 50 60 years hey
you're born into a family you hate that
family you're born into a body you
should hate that body you're born into a
country hate that country you're born
with certain natural desires suppress
those desires try to have the opposite
desires that's not going to be a recipe
for flourishing now speaking of UGL
women like in the Victoria Secret
catalog there's a story I don't have
time to get to it today I'll try to get
to it tomorrow but deep fake
porn but we've already had enough weird
sex stuff for today we're going to move
on to guests that I'm so excited about a
pal of mine going back back many many
years we were students together in
college two of the only conservatives at
our extremely liberal College Alec
Torres and Joshua Charles who I've
mentioned on this show before a former
Trump speech writer who has become one
of my favorite religious writers on all
of Twitter he's got these
amazing essays about he he converted
from protestantism to Catholicism but
their essays even if you're Protestant
even even if you're Hindu or whatever
his essays on the patristics on the
early church are so so good and they've
got a new book so head on over to the
meem segmentum uh the will be waiting
for you there the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
become a member use code NES canw a
checkout for two months free on all
annual
[Music]
plans